the administration today issued a strong
condemnation of a major foreign power
that routinely hacks American
infrastructure steals national secrets
technology personal information in huge
quantities the director of the FBI
called this country the greatest
long-term threat to America's well-being
Russia oh sorry excuse me China misread
that for more than two decades now of
course it has always been China
America's greatest geopolitical rival
you wouldn't know that though from
watching television even this week with
this new news about China there's only
one foreign power on the radar
considered a threat you know what it is
the Russians exploited a massive
backdoor into the foundation of our
democracy
Moscow's attack on American democracy
the work by Russian agents to try to
destabilize American democracy it's
everything you need to know about the
threat to our democracy the long term
damage is going to be the weaken our
democracy you have Republicans who are
silent and seemingly okay with this kind
of attack on our democracy these people
are so stupid it's amazing their
employees Michael Pillsbury not stupid
and employed director of the Center for
Chinese strategy the Hudson Institute
author of the remarkable book the
hundred year marathon China's secret
strategy to replace America as the
global superpower a strategy no longer
secret thanks to his book mr. pillsbury
joins us tonight thank you very much for
coming on so this seems like a
confirmation this announcement today of
what we may have known but still
striking yes I think when the director
of the FBI calls China our main rival
and then specifically said their goal is
to replace us as the global superpower
that's the subtitle of my book yes so
it's not just good news for me though
Tucker it shows the recognition of the
problem of China is now getting quite
widespread give us a scale of the
hacking efforts by the Chinese
government here well they're number one
by far more than the Russians they have
a number of techniques some of which
were revealed today formally classified
matters there's this wonderful term I
hope you'll start using called Stone
Panda it's the codename for the Chinese
unit that's been doing this sounds like
a restaurant but I
and it seems to according to this
declassified material it seems to go
back twelve years it seems to focus on
American companies the data that they
stolen can help them in negotiations
business negotiations with American
companies they also get trade secrets
its massive and it seems to be focused
on the high-end technology sectors that
China would need to dominate by 2030 or
2035 in order to be the world leader so
in other words they're going to steal
their way to global leadership let's put
it that way it's more polite than
domination and the FBI is blowing the
whistle today along with the Deputy
Attorney General the PD is as you may as
you know from the our local press
there's been a big leak that Steve
minuchin and the Treasury Department
we're going to offer sanctions today as
punitive for these things at DOJ and the
FBI are finding for some reason at the
last minute Treasury pulled out so they
weren't at the announcement and they're
not putting the sanctions forward so
this leak shows dissent inside the Trump
team and of course the Chinese have a
strategy that vice president pence spoke
about back in October that they want to
divide the Trump administration they
know their hawks and doves so this is a
good this is good news it's raises
public awareness for what China is up to
there are no actual sanctions announced
other than the indictment of these two
Chinese hackers out of possible 10,000
hackers let's say meanwhile there calls
for more Russia sanctions yes tells you
everything Michael is free thank you
very much for this and all you've done
on this topic thanks doctor